if you see these people they're
systematically
they always go against their own
principles what is the quran the quran
is the same thing with the prophet peace
be upon him she just
i think she's just bamboozled she's come
on a school trip
with a child if you think about russia
we should everyone should hate islam
islam should you know some people say
and there was statement i can't remember
who it was from he said
the way islam has been attacked if it
was any other religion it would have
crumbled
check out our sponsors nature's blend
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
your brothers and sisters and dear
friends some people live in darkness
and some prefer life and that's why
we're here
today i have a special guest i'm not
talking about myself i'm talking about
waleed
so i'm late please
i didn't run but i tried so bob and
sisters now we're going to get straight
into the video
in this video a few bizarre things
happen um and we're going to watch
inshallah
what this um coward has to say when i
call him a coward there's a reason
behind
you it how she's not faced by it look at
the sister she's just she's she's just i
think she's just
bamboozled she's come on a school trip
with her child
yeah and she's entered maybe this house
of parliament
yeah someone just telling her to take
her job it's just like
how do you react to that but i think
imagine you're going to somewhere and
they're saying yo
shave off your beard yeah yeah how do
you react to that i love because i know
you're not going to make me do that you
get it so the thing is i
i salute the fact she's just laughing
off like yeah okay you get it i
absolutely love that you know
[Music]
so this october will be about two years
ago
and the sun is there
and this is very interesting because
these people come with that you know you
believe in your god that's at home
yeah you you you have a religion this is
your religion
in the name of our secular principles to
ask the woman let's see to ask the woman
who accompanied the student to just
enter the room to have
the islamic veil removed
but not here today yeah okay this is
what i'm trying to say a lot of these
people like this atheist they pretend
like you know you guys believe in god we
don't
yeah brother you you are there's no
difference between us you
you're bound to worship something
allah's created all of us you're
bound to be enslaved to something you
are a slave to your secular your system
your secular laws yeah
and she is and you're saying in the name
as if it's like a deity in the name of
this can you please take you off here
and what's interesting is look at this
this woman is the council's president
mary quater defeat the name i hate the
french language sorry this is
an offence
interesting check this out yeah stop
people from wearing the veil during
meetings
what's happening right now this was this
was a year and a half ago yeah yeah
she's saying that the french
constitution doesn't stop a woman from
wearing the veil in meetings yeah okay
now in france
yeah okay that sums up in it i don't
know i don't think we need to carry over
yeah yeah we're just kind of done yeah
that is about a year and a half ago so
this is very important for us to
understand what's the reason why i want
to do that video
because what it shows is bro this was
about a year and a half ago you had some
idea maybe some of them didn't agree
with them
yeah now they're trying to pass it as a
law
they're under 18 you can't wear a hijab
yeah
and if i'm not mistaken there was
another law of command about
mother's oh my gosh i think what was it
there was another there was another
thing that i was saying that mothers
when they're bringing their child
children to school or in school or
something like that yeah well
there's something i can't remember you
guys probably put in the comment section
here those two things yeah
now it's just a year and a half and look
how things have changed where they're
going down the route
of now fully abandoned
and this is why it's very important that
if you see these people they're
systematically they always go against
their own principles what is the quran
the quran the same thing with the
prophet peace be upon him do you get it
they would go against their own
principles
yeah you know their own principles to go
far as killing the prophet
and this is what is this belief is that
you're bound to go against your own
principles but what's your take on them
that that was my decision okay i i just
feel like
in some way this i think obviously allah
says something that you think is bad for
you could be good for you
and i feel like in this sense i feel
like
allah is spreading islam by using these
people
yes like as soon as they said the hijab
is banned
look at everyone everyone's like putting
up you know posts
yeah memes yeah reposting hijab like
hijab is becoming
recognized it's trending hijab's
trending now and it's like allah is
using these people
they think they're trying to turn out
the light of allah but allah is using
them
to just like yes make the lao and the
the light
more clear for people like i said
earlier it says
yeah they try and i just feel like the
more people looking into it
people can just become muslims man and i
just feel like there's
just backfiring but it's just scary how
this is just the beginning of god knows
what's gonna happen yeah
and what even what makes it more
interesting a year ago two years ago
they tried to abandon the car
yeah and now the whole world wears in
the car yeah yeah yeah
you understand it's just like everyone
is forced to wear a face belt
after it was banned sweden sweden was
sweden i think sweden's
i remember they recently done that you
can't wear it in a cup but you have to
wear the face mask yeah
the hypocrisy that they live in actually
contradicting themselves
it doesn't make sense man and this is
the reason why allah subhanahu wa has
certain you know
registration rules in the quran because
these people who
live upon disbelief because allah says
in surah montana verse
8 allah does not forbid you from being
just and kind to those who do not fight
based on your faith and kick you out
your houses so allah is making it very
clear that
the disbeliever the one that's hostile
and the one that's not hostile so these
people okay you can see
outright they in front of this the uh um
raiding masjids they've been banning
certain charities that are doing nothing
nothing like
you know so the thing is you can see
systematically aki the hatred is there
and you know like you said
like they tried to uh to turn the light
to allah and people don't understand a
lot there's
in in where we live we have metaphysical
laws okay like we have gravity okay
i don't like it i don't i don't like
your phone but yeah we have gravity
this is a is a metaphysical law yeah
allah has met the physical laws in place
the physical laws are things we can't
see touch or fear however those things
in place one of the things that we have
is for example sadaka never makes you
fall
yeah yeah that's a principle so if you
went to your friend john i said to john
i've got 50 pound left in my pocket yeah
and i'm going to give it under charity
he's going to think you're dumb
in his logic he's thinking you've got 50
pounds but in your principles you
believe god is going to flip it it's
going to flip it yeah so the thing is
with this
metaphysical law like you said the more
they attack islam the more it bounces
back metaphysical principle
yeah the more you attack islam the more
it's going to spread yeah what you're
doing is you're doing a job for us in 9
11 or 9 11 happened by
a certain you know group that we all
condemn but the the when
the islamophobes use that to be like oh
yeah this is what islam says all you've
done is brought the amount of reverse
that came to islam
after 9 11 in my books it's like it
doesn't make sense if you think about
russian
we should everyone should hate islam
islam should you know some people say
and there was statement i can't remember
who it was from he said the way islam
has been attacked
if it was any other religion it would
have crumbled but
we see islam thriving more people come
into islam
and like i said before it's a
metaphysical law of law in place you
know what i don't get
you know people say islam is the fastest
growing religion yeah the world
like isn't it isn't it the biggest one
by now like how long are you going to be
saying is the cause of growing religion
like it is it's
i've been hearing that for the last 10
years man yeah do you understand
i just feel like it's projected by
numbers that for example that like the
sunni group yeah they have that for
example the catholics i think
it's a pastor catholic yeah yeah it's
surpassed the catholics already
but in totality for example it's nearly
like you know the different
denominations of christians
everyone knows about islam that's what
the prophet said he will enter every
household
and and how is it going to enter every
household one way or another and it's
upon the people who was listening and
watching this if you're not muslim and
you're watching this
it's upon you you've heard it via a
hijab hijab oh that's unfair
you're a person who have justice i'm
trying to say and if you value that look
into islam
and that's why you have so many
youtubers i've got a christian food
though so what do you think the people
of france
i'm doing right now like the muslims
what do you think because i got a friend
yeah he actually moved recently from
france because
he feared for his children yeah
since last year september has been here
oh well and um
it's settled now but what do you think
the rest of
the muslims are doing they think they're
suffering they think they've got exit
plan do you think that well well the
thing is they need to hold
their religion because you know what let
me tell you something it might be the
fact
maybe i'm not saying maybe it's from
allah you know you're not doing enough
for the deed maybe it might be after
that
because a lot of people like muslims
were too late yeah make my money
go on holidays i'm chilled um you're not
concerned about the dao where i talk to
people
aki allah trust me this you know it's
your duty
to do the dawah you know and if you
don't okay
you'll be you'll be uh oppressed i'm not
saying that's directly
but it might be for you guys to get
closer to your religion and that's
what's gonna happen
maybe maybe i i don't personally believe
that yeah because i feel like
yeah a lot he tests the people he loves
i personally believe that might be a
contest
and but you have to also bear in mind
that you know france has the highest
population in europe in terms of yeah
muslims yeah
like eight to 10 million yeah so in the
whole europe and they fear that but you
see that they fear that
they fear that bro they they have these
all principles of you know liberalism
and it's okay your religion
once they notice that the population is
growing yeah and it's starting to have
an impact
like they say with the hijab you're
scared of a woman walking down what do
you think is necessary okay the hijab is
getting mad what do you think what do
you think that's going on
this reminds me of nazi germany yeah
it's systematically bro
and they're going to come to a point
don't be twisted bro these guys these
french
what did these were algerians but they
brought their chopped heads off what
they
the isis does here they brought those
heads
and they have a little museum in france
with the chopped heads these people
actually i'm telling you yeah
if the time comes these very nations who
are liberal
and freedom democracy watch what happens
watch how they flip
go against on principles and start
persecuting muslims or tell them to go
back to your country now
that's what's gonna happen next i think
that's it man i think in a nutshell
brother sisters you know that's where we
come from and that's where we see it
um it's the first time i've come to see
brother walid in his little
uh shop here as you can see in the back
i know you guys have the background
um yeah you know you can check him out
i'll leave a little description in the
box below um yeah
it doesn't look far away and uh my wife
had some of her friends over
man got kicked out yeah you know yeah we
oppress our wives okay
so i thought i'll come and see what he's
meaning to come to him for a long time
and i thought you know what yeah let me
come see him and we've done this if you
want if you like you know we need to
take on the matter you want to see more
videos let us know as you guys know you
can miss me on instagram
or leave a comment in the section below
and tell us why don't you guys react to
this
until next time if there's anything
you'd like to see
the drama dance coming smell good yeah
it makes it make sure you smell good
yeah
okay yes smell fresh fresh like a boat
what what was it normally a yacht what
was that one called this
a victory yeah victory what's that for
the yacht owners yeah private yacht
private jets yeah yeah if you have
private jets uh i don't have a private
jet but
uh i'd have a private jet but i still
smell good
some people are in darkness and they
need light that's correct
i keep commenting you do not see the one
thing darkness light
it's too late